you see on the left how she almost has
this like feminine essence of her and
it's interesting because even when women
age and they get older but they don't
get work done there's something more
pure about the way they look there's
something more feminine and then on the
right it's almost like an older woman
trying to cosplay as a younger woman and
we can all see it maybe it's more
visually attractive slightly but there's
a difference between attraction and
beauty and there's something about a
woman that has gotten very little work
done that just ages I I don't want to
say better but more gracefully over time
and you you start to see these women
that are too invested in their looks and
I think a lot of women have been lied to
and they end up at 50 just looking kind
of nutty looking kind of crazy because
eventually Botox starts to fade and then
and then you know when you think about
it how much money did you spend on
yourself that you could have really
spent on your family